i hate online early morning routines
[Music]
i mean honestly how did we even get here
how did we all decide that the key to
having a happier more productive life is
just pushing our waking time earlier and
earlier in the day why do i see for so
long youtubers who work from home
kind of pushing this idea that having a
four or five am
morning routine is the key to success
when the likes of bill gates mark
zuckerberg
or elon musk are waking up at a 8am
morning so being a night owl who has
tried to change this a lot in the past
myself
i just wanted to make the case for the
non-guru
non-morning person type of people who
like me have been made to feel as though
the reason that we are not achieving our
dreams
is simply because we are not conscious
when the sun rises the first thing i
want to say before this video starts
is that most of us do not have a choice
anyway on when to start our days
we might have a crazy commute or work
starts at a specific time or we have
kids or other people in the house
who are just waking us up so we have to
be up to get them ready for school or
something so this video is not targeted
towards those people
this video is targeted towards people
like me who are night owls and who are
constantly
being told that we need to wake up
earlier i don't think there's a single
week of my life where i'm not told that
it's ridiculous for me to wake up at 9
00 a.m
and i read this quote that said that the
story about the early bird
just shows that the worm should have
stayed in bed so yeah i thought in the
end of the day i would just make a video
with all the counter arguments to waking
up early
that um i just wanted to put out there
so here it goes i'll be touching upon
three points
self-respect biology and my personal
experience so
starting with self-respect i absolutely
love this quote which i'm going to read
which says ours is a culture where we
wear our ability to get by
on very little sleep as a kind of badge
of honor that symbolizes work ethic or
toughness or some other virtue
but really it's a total profound failure
of priorities
and self-respect now i absolutely love
this there are so many things of which
sleep is one in the productivity realm
that tend to be actually quite terrible
when
i think of them saying things like oh i
haven't managed to talk to my family in
three weeks or you
have no idea how little time i have for
myself or i only managed to sleep three
hours last night
i don't know why we say this in the way
that it kind of implies that we're such
put together and productive people but
actually if you've just done this to be
productive
it's actually quite sad and it feels as
though there's no self-respect there
rather than it being something
incredible i don't i genuinely don't
think that there should be a pride in
being productive or structured or
waking up early when it goes against
your natural instincts and needs i think
that there are cases when it is good
to kind of go against yourself in doing
these things and that's when you're
helping others or when you're staying up
for family
but to do it just to kind of achieve
work goals
just to me feels a bit weird and
unnecessary the second point i will i
hope will clarify this a bit more has to
do with biology and there is scientific
evidence which suggests that there are
two types of people according to our
body clocks the morning larks and the
night owls and this is probably because
when we were living in tribes
some people would have to stay awake to
kind of hold guard on everyone else and
the night owls are the descendants of
those who would kind of prefer to do the
night's
shift and the morning larks were the
people who would prefer to wake up early
and do that sort of shift so there are
definitely among us people who
very naturally will wake up at 4 am i'm
absolutely not saying that those people
don't exist
but there are also people who are more
productive at night time and find it
very difficult to wake up early in the
morning and yes there are times where
you actually have to work against your
body clock if you have to wake up to
feed a baby or if you have to
travel or if you're doing shift work you
obviously have to work against your
natural
biology but i do think that constantly
fighting against it is just
not healthy and this is where i get
frustrated because there is kind of a
mismatch between the biology and our
social conventions
so in biology it's perfectly acceptable
that about half of the people
would find it very difficult to wake up
early in the morning and would rather
stay up very late at night and wake up
late
and the other half of people would find
it very difficult to stay up late
because they want to sleep up early and
naturally wake up early in the morning
which is absolutely fine but i feel as
though in society for some reason we've
gotten to the point
where we've kind of agreed amongst
ourselves that anyone who stays up late
at night is obviously very lazy
and waking up late in the morning is
also very lazy and unproductive
while the other people who wake up early
in the morning are just
more productive than the others and this
has led to a whole bunch of night owls
like myself trying to
shift our morning routines so we can
also fit in with this
yes if you wake up early in the morning
you will work better and that's where i
want to go to my last and third point
which is experience i have personally
tried to reset my body clock so
many times and it is possible
temporarily i can like stay up very very
late one night and then i'll have to
sleep early the next morning so then i
can wake up a bit
earlier the next morning um so if i put
an alarm on let's say at 8 or 7 am it's
not going to be as painful
but this is very temporary i will always
as soon as i am semi well rested at some
point i will go back to wanting to stay
up late and wake up late my natural
makeup time
always resets towards 9am for many many
years i've tried to change it and it
just goes
right back there and not only this even
if i'm well rested and i wake up early
in the morning
i find that i don't do productive work
in the morning i like to take things
slow and i don't feel like working
while i'm the kind of person who in the
afternoon or the evening or night even
at 3am i can do very productive work
so i don't think there is literally any
sort of difference and i don't think
that we should be thinking that these
people who want to wake up early
or are waking early have some sort of
advantage or upper hand over us i know a
lot of morning people who wake up at 5
a.m
and by the time it is lunch time they've
done so much work well i've done nothing
but come 6 p.m or 7 p.m they are ready
to wrap it up and there's no way that
they can even start working and that's
where i begin
so i would say overall i don't think
that sleep really affects much i think
that
within your means if you're lucky enough
to kind of somehow design your life in a
way that you can sleep and wake up when
you want to
you should just follow and trust your
body rather than looking at youtubers
online or looking at other celebrities
and thinking that
the secret to their success or something
that affects their success is their
sleep or wake-up time
what works for other people might
definitely not work for you if you're
also
curious on learning more about sleep i'm
currently watching the signs of sleep
documentaries over on curiosity stream
which are
very kindly sponsoring this video also
next watch
is a documentary on dreams and how
dreams happen which i
am personally so interested in ever
since i discovered that not everyone can
lucid dream
dreams are something that i'm very very
curious about and i might actually
talk about in a video at some point if
you're interested but yes
for a price of a takeaway you can use my
discount code in the description to get
a full
year's worth of curiosity stream access
and also
you can get access to nebula where me
and other educational creators have our
videos up for an ad-free experience
so if you want to join me over there the
link is down below so yeah i'm just
genuinely very very passionate about
this topic because it comes up again and
again in my personal life and yeah i
would genuinely love to hear your
thoughts on the matter
have you also kind of struggled with the
judgment of other people for your
sleeping routines
and what do you think about this in
general if you haven't read the book why
we sleep
slightly problematic book but it's great
i would definitely recommend it and yeah
that was everything for me don't believe
everything you think and thanks
bye